okay it's time to finish the project if
you want to follow along with my
solution you can download a copy of my
source code in the downloadable section
I started by creating new crops of the
images some of the images were fine but
for most of them i went with different
crops for different browser widths for
instance with the horses on medium sized
displays i zoomed in just a little bit
and then on small displays i zoomed in
quite a bit now you can actually see the
horses back in the HTML the picture
element has two types of children source
and image source is optional but image
is not the image here acts like a
fallback meaning that if none of the
sources get hit the image will be
displayed also for browsers that don't
support picture the image will be
displayed by default for each image I
set to sources alongside the image the
first source has a media query of min
with 750 pixels and the second has a
media query of 500 pixels for each image
I set to sources alongside the image tag
the first source has a media query of
men with 750 pixels and the second has a
media query of men with 500 pixels this
means that for any browser with a
viewport greater than 750 pixels the
images in this source tag will be shown
if the browser has a viewport with
greater than 500 pixels but not greater
than 750 this source tag will be shown
and then for any others the last image
tag will be shown which means that
basically any browser smaller than 500
pixels will be seeing this image for the
first source I decided to take advantage
of the source set attribute source that
allows you to change which image is
displayed based on a device pixel ratio
so for a 2x display I'm showing a 2x
image which is at 1600 pixels wide but
for 1x displays I'm just showing a 1x
image and 1x is default it doesn't need
to come at the end with the picture
element set up like so the browser is
being told to decide which image to
download base on its width and its
device pixel ratio this is really
awesome because you know that the
browser is only going to download the
image that meets its needs perfectly
talk about responsive and hey all of
this still works within the figure tag
that
is using before so here's a figure
caption because why not and of course I
made sure to set all of my alt
attributes the only image that didn't
get an alt attribute is the SVG logo at
the top because it doesn't really mean
anything here so how does all this look
I'll go ahead and test first things
first I'll test whether or not these
images are changing based on browser
width so here's the large image of the
horses at less than 750 pixels I see a
much tighter crop of them which looks
good and then once the browser drops
below 500 pixels there's the tightest
crop of the horses so it looks like the
picture element is working to test
whether or not source set is working
I've gone ahead and refresh the page
while emulating an iPad with the width
of 1024 pixels and a device pixel ratio
of one you would expect that only 1x
images are being downloaded in fact
that's what you see check out how in the
network tab only 1x images are being
downloaded as a test i'll change the
device pixel ratio to two and hit
refresh and check it out 2x images are
being downloaded that's a pretty clear
sign that the picture element is working
awesome and then for the fun of it i can
even emulate what the experience would
be like on mobile I set the network
throttling to 3g and hit refresh and it
looks like the page loads in just under
4 seconds which all things considered
isn't too bad and then and so voila
there's the blog I made a few other
changes like making the top image a full
width banner image and you can check out
those changes if you check out the
source code in the downloadable section